derek is with us in denver hi Derek how
are you
I'm blessed thank you for asking how are
you better than I deserve
how can I help my question today is how
do I I'm wrestling with the decision to
take a job that would be my dream job
but it would be for a salary decrease
and just trying to figure out how to
evaluate whether take that position or
not okay what what is the what about it
makes it your dream job I mean so I'm
passionate about that's what I think I'm
gifted at what I've been told I'm gifted
at just what I've been working towards
in it you know for probably over a
decade so why does it have to pay less
um it's the nature of the job is it's in
the outdoor industry is that out these
outdoor leadership outdoor leadership
yes help me with that I don't know what
that means um well as a professor at a
Christian college running outdoor
Leadership Program oh okay so what about
that is the dream job the outdoor
leadership part of the professor part um
being an outdoor in the outdoor industry
in a Christian environment is the dream
part okay all right um well I would want
to if what do you make now about 74 and
what would you make there 57 okay then
then I want you to have a plan to go to
174 okay living your dream and maybe the
professorship is just the basis for that
in other words maybe it's time for you
to start a company that is a Christian
outdoor company and you use some of the
things you do in your professorship
professorship to be able to do that well
and to do it accurately you obviously
been around that business world in that
business model or that ministry model
for some time and believe me there are
people in the outdoor industry that make
a couple hundred a year easy and so I
you know and and in a Christian
environment that certainly can be done
so I just want you to have something
where this dream evolves rather than so
many people just automatically assume if
I
do what I love it means I have to make
less great and that's just not true
doesn't have to be true um I mean you
know so it's about how you apply the
aspects of what you love in the
marketplace you're just taking a teacher
position here but that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean you can't teach and it
doesn't mean you can't lead and it
doesn't mean you can't create in the
outdoor a Christian outdoor industry
space and make a whole lot more then you
make off this professorship to where the
professorship becomes a side gig I'll
give you an example that I've got a good
friend of mine who is a professor and
teaches in a Christian college and loves
it absolutely loves it he's also a New
York Times best selling author in the
space that he's in and speaks all over
the world and makes three times as much
on his books and speaking as he does the
professorship but it's all the same
material sure it's just how he applied
it in the marketplace does that make
sense
absolutely and so yeah I think there's
plenty of opportunity here but I would
use the step back with the idea that
it's going to be a step back to become a
stepping stone okay and that's the only
way I would do it if you're going to
just move down and call that your dream
I question your dreaming my life don't
do well as how about let's have a plan
to immediately upgrade your income to at
least your old income and have a long
term plan to make it just awesome
because I think living your dream part
of living your dreams getting paid for
it and I you know or making so stinking
much money somewhere that you don't have
to get paid for it or whatever but in
your case I think there's a way to do
ministry in the marketplace that's real
and that that is a different kind of an
environment and certainly you're in the
place to do that in the Colorado
marketplace definitely without doors
thing